welcome back everybody to the david
pakman show luke beasley here filling in
for david today while he is away taking
care of his new baby
if you like what you see here definitely
go subscribe to my youtube channel by
searching luke beasley on youtube if you
want to get the video form or luke
beasley on any podcast listening
platform if you just want to listen
father's day was over the weekend as i'm
sure you're aware and a lot of people
spend father's day doing different
things but
things like spending time with family or
if you're a father maybe
you have your family surround you and
give you appreciation
go out barbecuing whatever you do
something fun like that but not
not if you're the former president
donald trump trump spent father's day
angrily sending out messages on his
social media site truthsocial just
absolutely losing it
so here's the first
sweet father's day message
from donald j trump
the highly partisan unselects are trying
to create i'm not going to do that the
whole time are trying to create a fake
narrative for whatever reason but only
with evil intention that he
knew the election was stolen this is
completely false i felt the election was
rigged and stolen i have from the very
beginning and i have only gotten
stronger in that belief with time and
large amounts of additional evidence
improved in my mind i have and have had
no question and many people would be
willing to attest
big bold all caps all throughout that
but the unslecks don't want to hear
them
okay well he started off strong father's
day but then
then he cools off maybe no what let's
see you ready for this
witch hunt that was his next message all
caps witch hunt that's it
it's too much former president uh surely
now he's gonna wrap it up
enjoy his father's day spend some time
eating a big mac with ivanka no
i am leading in every poll by a lot and
the democrats are doing everything they
can to change that even if it's another
russia russia russia hoax mueller scam
impeachment waste of time or whatever
the same lying people saying the same
kind of thing i only want two and then
in all caps make america great again so
to the polling thing he is doing a lot
better in polling than he probably
should be that's crazy uh of the last
four he's beating biden in two so
biden's winning in two he's winning in
two
not completely accurate what he said but
it's still there's some truth to it that
he is leading in recent polls that's
frightening
and next he addresses the georgia phone
call that happened of course where he
asked the secretary of state to find him
11 000 whatever votes
that would help him flip the election
to being a win for him my phone call to
the georgia secretary of state with many
other people including numerous lawyers
knowing knowingly on the line was
absolutely perfect and appropriate yes
it was a perfect call and so was the
second call for which the washington
post was forced to do a major and
somewhat embarrassing retraction thank
you
okay so the georgia call was fine even
though i was trying to pressure a
secretary of state to find 11 000
something votes that would help me win
the election even though i didn't
perfect phone call
well finally to wrap it up i have to be
fair
he did say at the very end i want to
wish everyone a beautiful father's day
filled with peace
love
and compassion no he didn't say that at
all um i have so many witnesses to
everything good that that sentence is so
weird i have so many witnesses to
everything good
but the highly partisan and one-sided
unselect committee of political hacks
has not interest in hearing has not
interest in hearing or seeing them
this witch hunt could all be ended
quickly if they did
so a little bit of a typo there
not interest they have not interest
very fascinating um
but instead of hanging out with his
children where they can say you're a
great father they can lie and tell them
that
eric
don ivanka no instead he's maybe he was
with them i don't know but not spending
quality time because instead he was
ranting and raving
about
all of those things
my audience knows i read i read a ton of
books i read nonfiction i read fiction
at night i'm always trying to consume
information and the truth is i don't
have the time to read every non-fiction
book that i would like to read one thing
i do not have time to add to what i'm
reading in paper form
is more history but i want to know about
history and that's where our sponsor
blinkist comes in blinkist doesn't
replace reading books cover to cover the
way i love to do but for example with
everything going on right now with roe v
wade i wanted more of a detailed history
of roe v wade in the united states so on
blinkist i was able to get a 15-minute
condensed audiobook of the mary ziegler
book abortion and the law in america roe
v wade to the present and in 15 minutes
i get a great overview blinkist also has
slide presentations that will take you
about 15 minutes to go through so
it's not to replace reading it's in
addition to for me you get the key
takeaways from blinkist from the books i
would certainly otherwise miss out on
you can try blinkist for free for seven
days and get a 25 discount off of a
subscription at blinkist.com pacman the
link is down below